The Joe Rogan Experience that was
Gustafson in his best now that in the
Jon Jones fight I remember the Jon Jones
fight the first one when John didn't
train you know that's that's how you see
the difference because look at the
second fight they have a second fight
well they take him down but you have to
also say this is the second fight how
was that before or after Gustafson
fought Rumble
oh that's a good question rest in peace
Rumble
apparently uh he had some form of uh I
think it was like Non-Hodgkin's lymphoma
or something along those lines yeah I
don't know if that's public we should
find out if that's public knowledge I
think it was I think I read that I
couldn't pronounce the words and that
sounds like it was yeah I shouldn't say
it if it wasn't public knowledge so if
it's not public knowledge we should edit
it out you know I'm almost positive I
just read that in an article the other
day but yeah that was that was I was on
the 38 years old man yeah I did the UFC
quintet with him who's me clay GUI to
him Gilbert Burns
uh Anthony Smith but yeah he was a
that's I think my only really
interaction with him dude [ __ ] good
dude
yeah Non-Hodgkin's lymphoma a rare
immune disorder called H uh hlh yeah
horrible 38. such a nice guy and the
biggest middle the biggest welterweight
that's ever walked the face when he was
a welterweight I know dude I saw him in
between fights once and I go Anthony how
big are you and he goes 230 pounds to
30. what the [ __ ] he walked in looking
like a Greek god he was so judgment I'm
like it wasn't fat at all like how do
you get that little how do you make 170.
he was gigantic he had he always had
issues making 170 there right oh yeah
well he missed it a bunch of times and
then he fought Vitor at 85. and Rumble
was like this guy that you never knew
what you were gonna get
if if he was like
ready to go and in shape and and and
prepared
Jesus he could be one of the most
dangerous guys of all time yeah but he
was kind of uh you know at least early
on in his career inconsistent until he
moved up in weight then when he moved up
and wait look what he did in the light
heavyweight Division and I maintained
that most of what was holding him back
was just the dread of making that weight
this is dread the guy goes up two-way
classes and is knocking out everybody
with one punch at light heavyweight yeah
170 should have never been imagine that
inside of his career he's fighting 35
pounds up and destroying people knocking
out Glover with one punch knocks out
Gustafson bro he not he [ __ ] everybody
up except DC yeah DC just uses wrestling
he fought DC twice right yeah right yeah
caught him but DC was like God damn I
don't want to fight this [ __ ]
again dude he's so damn dangerous
rumble's so dangerous that's a scary
yeah he was so dangerous he had power
that was I remember when he hit Glover I
was like oh did his tooth go flying was
that Glover's tooth he made somebody's
tooth go flying yeah I don't know if it
was Glover's yeah uppercut God damn he
was a Powerhouse yeah possessing that
[ __ ] power in his hands because he
doesn't need to be like oh it is it is
global oh yeah because he doesn't need
to really be accurate either he can hit
you like anywhere in the head and that's
night night bro he could hit your
shoulders and you'd be dizzy he might
get knocked out it's crazy he just had
that Preposterous power yeah that oof
watch this uppercut I think oh that was
like crazy just like a thud that's
Rumble man that's why everybody was
talking to rumble his tooth yeah yeah oh
oh at least he woke up didn't know what
the [ __ ] happened no one counted my
takedown on Peter or two points I think
that was two but it'll take them to the
end of the first I think it was a
takedown did his knees go to the ground
yeah DC gets mad when they don't give up
takedowns